nevada has been flagged with very high
case rate in fact this is going on in
every county statewide so on today's
cobit response update call director
caleb cage says
with these numbers at this there's also
been an increased demand for testing as
well
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
joining us on the call as well and
telling us
what they're going to be looking for in
the coming days sally
denise caleb cage says they are well
aware of the many gatherings on new
year's eve as well as private gatherings
tonight they are
asking if you are out in large crowds
act as if you have covet
and quarantine also be mindful of your
interactions with others in the coming
days
you are also urged to get tested between
five to seven days of potential exposure
also on the briefing today duane young
the deputy administrator of the division
of health care financing and policy
also known as medicaid he says data
shows that
medicaid accounts for less than 30
percent of patients
awaiting discharge 40 percent of those
individuals are on medicare
and the remaining are commercial payers
we are coordinating among hospitals and
skilled nursing facilities
to address the needs of these patients
dhhs has formed
a hospital discharge strike team that
assists facilities
in moving pace recipients by working
daily with managed care organizations on
member updates
finding placement for fee for service
recipients assisting with eligibility
for those who are uninsured
also discussed in the briefing if we
have had any of the new varying covet
cases in nevada
the answer to that no cases as of right
now reporting live in the newsroom sally
jaramillo 8 news now